in our anecdotal sample i will say there
is a strong but not absolute bias
towards people who are at least somewhat
vaccinated with a globe of 19 vaccines
that's true we have seen some people who
are not vaccinated but the number of
people who have been hit with
substantial disease who are vaccinated
is conspicuous
um which you know raises questions which
i guess we'll get to later in the
podcast about um efficacy
of the vaccines and also possible
downsides right which were never
properly accounted for in the fairy tale
that we were given about how these
things were supposed to function the
risk that they would be
counterproductive was never described it
wasn't maybe maybe that's a good a good
place to segue here but
uh
one thing that is always worth saying
is that specifically the mrna vaccines
but i guess also the adenovirus vectored
vaccines
the effects of them on the body are
likely to be very similar to the effects
of of the virus itself because of course
you know to the degree that the disease
that coveted as produced by stars kobe 2
is largely about the spike protein what
the mrna vaccines are doing is having
getting your body to produce the spike
protein over and over and over and over
again so it can be hard to tell the
difference and is there a chance that
having been exposed to the spike via a
vaccine upon being exposed to the actual
complete virus you are more likely to
have a response at this point of course
it's possible um i want to
add two things here a couple couple
things one
is i think the better way to do this is
not to say that the two things are very
similar it's to say that there is a
subset of the effects of the virus and
the vaccines there is a subset of the
effects of these things that overlaps
yes that is that which is there
turns out spike protein is a problem in
and of itself right to the extent that
both uh the virus and the vaccines
produce spike protein there will be an
overlap in whatever
uh
whatever counterproductive
physiology follows from that then there
are a lot of things that are not
overlapping right for example
you would expect that which is caused by
lipid nanoparticles to accompany the
mrna vaccines but not covid or the dna
based adenovectored vaccines etcetera so
there are lots of subsets you know some
big venn diagram of
stuff but the other thing and i must
tell you
i found jonathan cooy's uh recent
podcast um
uh with uh i'm stumbling to find his
twitter handle anyway i'll come back to
it in a second but
uh jonathan cooy's recent podcast
explored
at a level of technical detail that was
very hard to follow i think even even he
had trouble following elements of it
but explored some of the
massive
differences between
the
likely differences that are downstream
of the way these vaccines induce the
production of spike
that suggests that what is circulating
in vaccinated people
is not entirely spiked protein based on
the um
the uh
the construction
model right that basically
essentially the pseudo-uridines that
were introduced so pseudo-uradine is
something that does occur naturally
nature uses this mechanism but it uses
it very very sparingly and we have
almost no understanding of what it does
and why it shows up where it is
the manufacturers that basically turned
your cells into a
vaccine factory
used it universally they replaced all
the uracils right and
what i learned from this podcast that i
did not know
is that the ribosomes are not
indifferent to it that actually this
neither the ribosomes nor the trnas
deal with this as a uracil what happens
is effectively
an unpredictable phenomenon where there
are lots of errors introduced every time
because the ribosome is built around uh
hitting a uracil and
reading the information this way a
pseudo-uridine has a very different
effect and so so
uh i have not seen this podcast with uh
jj kowi uh but it sounds like in your
venn diagram of the ways that uh the
vaccines could cause health problems and
the ways that covid cause health
problems there's this venn diagram as
you said and the spike protein
affects the effects from a spike protein
are not entirely overlapping in part
because there's additional spike protein
with pseudo-uridine
spike protein pro created by
pseudo-uridine mrna effects that will
not be found in the original covid which
is itself of course a franken virus but
we've now got like a franken a franken
vaccine for a franken virus
and uh therefore not even the spike
protein is exactly the same right and
what's more
again this is not my area of expertise
but
our vaccinologist friends and others
with more
of a molecular focus will correct me if
i'm wrong here but this also makes an
argument in favor of the dna based
vaccines because the dna vaccines will
not have pseudo-uridine in the rna that
results in the encoding of the spike
proteins right
so anyway because there's no uracil in
dna
uh right so the point is
at the point you get to rna it's a
normal rna because the mechanism is
different so if i've got that wrong
somebody will tell me but um certainly
seems i can't see it now it would be
wrong
[Music]